Last week for the first time in 17 years, Fox News
fell to 3rd place in prime time cable news ratings
among 25 to 54 year old viewers
this is within the so called "big three" cable news networks
that's CNN, MSNBC, and of course Fox News
So prime time means: 8-11pm -uh uh -
I don't know if it's eastern time or if it's measured in each time zone. But anyway,
prime time is 8-11pm
the 25-54 demographic is considered by advertisers as sort of the most important demographic marketing wise
So it's a pretty standard metric for how a show is doing
Fox launched in 96 and they've not been in third place since June of the year 2000.
Almost 17 years to the day.
MSNBC is now first with 611,000 viewers
In that demographic close to 2.5million viewers overall
Fox News, under 500,000 viewers
In what is called "The Demographic"
And 2.4 million viewers overall, that puts CNN right in the middle. In second place.
So I think there are a couple things this is connected to. One is the Trump scandals, right.
You've got more and more Trump scandals. When you watch Fox News, it's like everything is fine. So,
That might work if you only watch Fox News and you have no idea that it's scandal-after-scanda
But if you're tuning into something else for even a few minutes a day or a week, you're going to realize that when you watch Fox News
and they're pretending that this is a completely normal presidency that you're just not getting the full story. That's one aspect of it.
The other, that might be, is that Bill O'Riely's show is off the air. Although the median age for Bill O'Riely's viewers was something like the low 70's
So it actually wouldn't have that big an impact on this demographic, but the way Fox News is covering the president HAS to
playing a roll here.
And I think it has a lot to do with the Russia scandal because, we don't know this yet for sure, but this could be the biggest government scandal in American history.
Even more so than Water Gate. And if they're just kind of missing out on it, it's so news worthy and objectively interesting
And if the other stations are covering it and they're downplaying it as some sort of conspiracy, they're just not going to get the same ratings.
Take this as an example, as news broke about Donald Trump leaking information to the Russians
in the oval office, Tucker Carlson was on and he did this long segment about how the leak was a terrible thing.
The fact that this information was leaked was a terrible thing.Later that night on The Five...
The whole show, again, was just on the fact that the transcript of the conversation leaked, right. Not about the content, the fact that the president leaked this information.
They're just talking about how it's terrible that this transcript leaked and now we know what was said.
And then Jesse Waters even said that the investigations into the leakers would be top priority, THATS THE STORY from Fox News.
Not the fact that it was, you know, horribly concerning regarding national security and then Hannity was on the next time slot
He just talked about violence at anti-trump protests and how unfairly everyone is treating Donald Trump.
So, if you're only in the Fox News bubble, maybe it makes sense that that is what you tune in and see
If you're aware of what's going on at all, you're going to see that and say "I am just not getting anything close to the full pictire here"
Yeah and it doesn't help that there is so much turnover there. Of course Bill O'Riely is off the air and Shawn Hannity is taking a vacation this week because he's losing so many advertisers
Yeah, we don't know if that's BECAUSE of that. It's coincidental. It's another one of these coincidences Pat.
That's what happend with Bill O'Riely too right? Tucker Carlson can only be in so many places at once.
And in fact, right, yeah, very nice I liked that. On the bonus show today we will be talking about Shawn Hannity's abrupt vacation
After losing so many advertisers. We're also going to talk about, it wasn't just Volkswagen who might have been messing with emmissions numbers
And we'll also talk about some very interesting revelations about facebook's internal rule-book
on what is allowed in terms of sexual content, terroristic related content, violent content on Facebook
All of those storys and more on today's bonus show. Sign up at davidpakman.com/membership